[Music]
okay so first of all Rob Marshall I know
he movie proposed to you who did and I
want to know if you know that he
proposed to everybody else he even
proposed to Meryl via email he didn't
even give her a formal proposal and
apparently she just went yes yes yes yes
yes how do I feel about my proposal was
definitely the most charged and fashion
I'm just gonna say you know Meryl got an
email I got a full phone call okay I
don't wanna be competitive with Meryl
but if I'm better than an email listen I
don't want to like hey it's not for me
to say like no and I was the first
proposal I will be his first and only
one he will always be the first you'll
always be the first um I'm gonna go in
with a singer here Oh God there is this
saying where you look in the mirror and
you say practically perfect in the film
and then there's another saying in the
film called Cerf Louie which means kind
of the opposite everything apart tell me
something about yourself that is
practically perfect and something that
is Cerf Louie I'm not practically
perfect it's just for her I'm not
practically perfect kaflooey is much
more sort of on par with how I operate
falling apart at the seams I mean if I
had to if I had to drive anywhere
without Google Maps I'm a girl could
fluid oh that was Merrill right that
what what did you just pull out there
cold nose um so I know your husband John
pride yes when he saw sat through the
films there's a whole theme because Rob
apparently cried Lynne cried as a child
he couldn't get through the original
head joke we like men who cry and laugh
I will personally love it I've never
found one should say but have you cried
and when I want to know when John cried
please tell me you use that line well
that's enough of that
know how cold that I watched it by
myself the first time and I smiled and
laughed and sort of cried most of the
way through it but then when Rob came in
after I'd finished watching it and that
was when
I couldn't speak I was sort of it was
like that ugly oh I love the ugly cry
scream cry yeah kind of thing like that
when you start to suck in it was like it
was bad it was my god it was not I did I
couldn't pull it together
it was all do what
[Music]
I'm just gonna go in with a zinger okay
so there's a saying or a couple sayings
or phrases in the movie one of them is
practically perfect and one of them is
Cerf Louie which is the total opposite I
want to know what about you is
practically perfect and what is curve
Louie is very little of about me that is
practically perfect the only the only
talent I have that is on display in this
movie that I'm actually very good at is
sliding down banisters on my butt and I
got to do it one second in this movie
very proud of that
everything else is cerf Louie on its way
it's a practically perfect and took a
lot of hard work Oh pish-posh I totally
disagree with you about that one um so I
know as a kid you loved this movie but
you could only get to feed the birds and
then you would start to feed the bird
messed me up man and there's a little
reference to feed the birds and the Dick
Van Dyke scene did you cry when you
watch this film have you cried every
time every all the three times you've
seen it have you cried listen I'm a
terrible judge of it I'm an easy cry but
the but really honestly what was magical
about that sequence when we shot dick
Van Dyke's monologue were as you
mentioned the orchestration sort of very
subtly quotes feed the birds
he finished the monologue and then there
was this sort of silence and no one know
what to do and it's because Rob was so
overcome that he couldn't say cut and it
was the first time he really lost it on
set so we were all so I know you've also
said that you loved the Little Mermaid
and you loved Sebastian the crab and
under the sea and I wonder if there's
the best portrayal of a composer in
cinema history it's like Amadeus and
Sebastian the crab wears the rainy did
you draw any influence from Sebastian or
anywhere else random for this for this
role as you know my biggest my biggest
sort of research assistant on this was
my son I used to going on three and and
really what this movie is about is that
we're born with sort of limitless
imagination and then we forget as we get
older and I had a kid who was firmly in
that you could hand him a stick and he
would dance to step in time for an hour
on his own and so he was he was much
anytime I needed to find that innocence
I had an expert in my home
[Music]
MARY POPPINS who came back you seemed
hardly to have aged at all really one
never discusses a woman's age Michael
would have hoped I taught you better
so congratulations on an amazing film
there is one thing that I'm noticing
when I hear people talk about this film
whether they're talking about this one
or the original it's tears there is a
through-line where Rob Marshall I think
it was the first movie he ever saw and
he cried I don't think Lynn said he
could get through the first one without
crying
and then you apparently made John
Krasinski cry when he watched the film
for the first time it was something with
your scene that made him cry anything he
couldn't stop crying throughout have you
guys kept on the tradition or have you
cried watching any of them and sort of
like what the original meant to you but
I have been delighted to be to have had
an opportunity to watch the first film
again which I hadn't seen since I was
three or four yeah but but but when I
was three or four it was my world you
know I was obsessed with it so but I
felt more us just really a sense of
being enchanted again and delighted then
almost like I was three or four again
and how did you feel what making John
Krasinski cry throughout well that's
sweet isn't it yes that's nice but I
think it's because he's recently I mean
he's a new dad yeah so it's touching
yeah um well yeah it's very the first
one was was very touching seeing these
kind of grown-up oddball parents who'd
been so sort of distant from their
children and quite absent suddenly
finding joy in them and that was very
moving and let's go fly our kites number
at the end was even as a child I mean I
wasn't this required but I remember
feeling you know and in this movie is
very much very emotional because it's
about grieve it's about the loss of a
mother and a wife Michael's wife and has
just recently died before the movie
begins and so there's a lot that touches
on things that really make you feel sad
and they'd them the way that I think Rob
has directed it where he
he doesn't sort of lay on the emotion he
doesn't sit on the emotion too much he
doesn't overdo it yeah and everybody's
trying to be brave in the face of this
tragedy including the children and that
really makes you cry when you see
children trying to be brave about their
own mother dying you're just like oh my
goodness oh so Rob famously proposed to
Emily but movie proposed when he when he
brought the idea of doing Mary Poppins
did you get a proposal from Robert how
would you how are you brought on board
officially I met him in his apartment in
New York and and he pitched the movie to
me yeah I haven't seen the script but he
just told me the story and told me that
he wanted to make a movie that started
off where you met that grown-up bank's
children so he proposed to you to really
really want me over I said yes and we
did his proposal did you did you get
proposed to as well I guess a kind of
suppose yeah it was extremely charming
and very you would say yes I mean yes no
no he meant to battle he'd do anything
yeah young he's he's that kind of thing
yeah and then last question there's
there's a couple of phrases or words in
the movie practically perfect is one of
them and Cerf Louie is another and
they're both sort of the opposite ends
of the spectrum can you tell me either a
practically perfect moment you had onset
or one that just went kaflooey because
you had so much you know there's so much
to coordinate on set well practically
perfect um was was I mean more than
perfect actually was Dick Van Dyke when
he came on and delivered this just
extraordinary performance and none of us
we'd all rehearse with each other
for weeks on end and hadn't you know and
it all seen each other perform but he
had just arrived and just literally
arrived walks onto the set goes up onto
a table and did a dance and then sat
down and delivers perfect monologue and
our jaws were on the floor it was
amazing and beautiful and I mean not
practically perfect it was perfect the
odd part yeah I think my first day of
filming was a bit tough Louie okay I
hate birthdays even is really odd we
study
yeah we started with a scene right near
the end of the film yeah even though
we'd had like lots of rehearsals it all
felt a bit like oh this isn't a good
start you remember we forget but then it
did go uphill yeah it got practically
perfectly
so you've been off filling the
children's heads with stuff and nonsense
difficult what it's like to be a child
first of all I'm gonna call you out a
little bit because Emily said that you
movie proposed to her when you told her
about this film but I'm also hearing
that you proposed to Ben you propose to
Emily you proposed to Lin so are you
changing up the proposal every time and
how do you movie propose that's such a
great question you know listen I have
the greatest group of actors in this
film and it was such a thrill for them
all to say yes it's all my first choices
you know Wow
I mean I saw no one else for these roles
but these great actors and so I I guess
I hope that they felt when I movie
proposed to them my love of the first
film my great desire to make this film
have the same spirit but also create
something completely new and original at
the same time and I hope they felt the
love that I feel for their work and that
I honestly believed it in my deepest
heart that they could embody these
characters with such passion and such
talent you know they're all so
extraordinary and I think you know
that's the hope that you know that
they'll say yes to that proposal you
said you got a yes every single time
you've got a great track record I mean I
even got here's my favorite from Meryl
Streep I actually emailed her because I
know her well having worked at thrown
into the woods I said would you ever
consider blah blah blah blah blah and
she this is what she wrote yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes so that was a
few yeses getting one yes from Meryl so
talking about the original I know is the
first movie you ever saw as a child you
cried I'd then there's a theme of Tears
John Krasinski cried when he saw it
Lin said he couldn't get through the
original without crying I've seen it
three times I've cried every single time
I talked to me about your tears I find
it you know what I just watched it again
at the premiere in LA it was our big
world premiere was a huge screen at the
Dolby theater and I was sitting with you
know this extraordinary audience who was
just loving it and giving it such you
know I don't notice all of their heart
watching it I felt it and in the
audience and and it's just an emotional
movie it's emotional people for for
people who know the first film I think
you you don't I mean because it was a
nostalgia or something that's what I
feel but I cry just him as much out of
joy
that's what it is though it's not it's
not ugly too you know it's sort of like
a joyous feeling it's like just
remembering your childhood or
remembering that there's wonder in the
world it's it's somehow very deep yeah
well talking about you paid such a Maj
to the original while making it fresh
and there's so many elements I wish I
had time to ask you about but I know you
did hand-drawn animation you brought
animators out of retirement
yes I'm wondering about the sound too
because like an old-school animation you
had to use random things you didn't have
the technology did you do that with the
sound as well well no I have the
greatest most sophisticated sound of her
him but I also wanted them to understand
that I wanted things that didn't seem
artificial dude I mean I wanted it
obviously feel very organic coming from
the story and when I wanted to create
two worlds a very real London and then
sort of these Fantasia's you know that
was so important for me I mean it's just
because you just want to be lifted and
we wanted to find different worlds like
underwater what's that sound like what
does it sound like inside a china bowl
you know for that whole sequence you
know what are these and I want you to
feel it viscerally not just sort of
seeing it but it feel it here at all
everything is there any um you know
things are obviously on the page and you
bring on these great actors but is there
any specific either with Lin any of the
actors that you went wow I didn't expect
that I remember there was a hilarious
moment from Emily Blunt where she just
made up a line that's in the film it's
one of my favorite lines in the film
that's it she's watching Jack and Jane
right off which he's kind of like sort
of arranged to make sure that they meet
and she's so happy within she you see
her kind of loving that and then she
changes like Mary Poppins so quickly she
was well that's enough of that and she
walks off and it's so funny and it's so
Emily Emily has such a great sense and
it was so you know what I love about
actors is when they actually own the
role it's like their role and so on and
so she found these moments and found
that great hilarious line Wow the
children did you know that I loved that
you knew that um the children that you
cast yes
what's so spectacular
films and you really took the time to
make me care about that oh well so what
the casting process did you have them
read all together you know what we saw
hundreds and hundreds of kids in England
and by the end you know we were sort of
whittling it down and I wanted to see
how they would work together so yes by
the end we had the three of them
together and read together and it was
there was a magic I felt they were
brother and sister and you know why
because they're real kids they're not
sort of showbiz kids I really was so
concerned that we didn't do that I
wanted to create a real family with you
know the Umbra --nt Ben Whishaw as the
father and these three great children
and of course Emily Mortimer the
fabulous Emily murderer as their aunt
Jane and I wanted to feel like it was a
real family that you really care about
and Julie Walters of course the great
Julie Walters as the housekeeper Ellen
like a real family that we really
believed in
you